deliver a check and uh now the king is  as safe as houses on that d2 square  and uh unfortunately  anna is just simply going to go to the  eighth row and become a queen okay we  have a tricky move from artemiev he uh  puts his knight to c6 and hopefully you  know has his finger crossed that maybe  the anna will drop yeah so white's pawn  now it's promotion squares covered  black's queen is protecting it from  behind but magnus just grabbing another  pawn he actually created a pin along the  sixth rank towards the black king he's  forced the black king even further away  right now and with this last move  carlson attacking the black queen he's  forced the black queen to take that  white pawn anna has dropped off but  she has given up her life for a night  and white is a whole night up and that  has caused me to resign wow the hero of  the game anna wins magnus crossing the  first game of today are tamiya shaking  his head this is dramatic for the  russian